turning
to covet i want to update you on our
progress
and in particular on the storm clouds
that are gathering over
parts of the continent a
new wave of kovid has steadily thr swept
through
central europe and is now affecting our
nearest neighbors in western europe
our friends on the continent have been
forced to respond with various degrees
of new restrictions from full lockdowns
to lockdowns for the unvaccinated to
restrictions on business opening hours
restrictions on social gatherings
we don't yet know the extent to which
this new wave will wash up on our
shores but history shows that we cannot
afford to be complacent
indeed in recent days there have been
rising cases here in the uk
so we must remain vigilant because there
is one lesson we can draw from the
current situation in europe
those countries
with lower vaccination rates have tended
to see bigger surges in infection and in
turn being forced to respond with
harsher measures
while those countries with higher
vaccination rates have so far
fared better
and this shows us once again that if we
want to control the epidemic here in the
uk and if we want to avoid new
restrictions on our daily lives we must
all get vaccinated as soon as we are
eligible
today
following the recommendation of the
independent joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
we're making second jabs available to
all 16 and 17 year olds from 12 weeks
after their first dose
and we're making boosters available to
all those aged 40 to 49 from six months
after their second dose boosts as you
know are already available for all those
over 50 those with underlying health
conditions and those working on the
front line of our nhs and in care homes
and
let me explain why that booster is
absolutely crucial
because over time the protection from
two jabs starts to wane
but that third jab
boosts protection back up to over 90
percent against systematic infection
so far around 12.6 million people across
the uk have had that booster including
in england around three quarters of all
people over 70
and 80
of eligible older people in care homes
but many more people who are eligible
have not yet come forward and so if you
are one of those people please go and
get that third jab because
it would be an utter tragedy if after
everything we've been through people who
had done the right thing
by getting double vaccinated
ended up becoming seriously ill or even
losing their lives
because they allowed their immunity to
wane
by not getting their booster
and if you haven't even had one dose
it's not too late in fact there's never
been a better time to get that vital
protection as we head into winter so
please please go and get vaccinated to
protect yourself and others and in doing
so we can help to ensure that we can
continue in the way that we are
sticking to our plan of using
vaccination to control
this virus